[Musique]
que c'est vrai que la vérité me paraît
être très souvent et de plus en plus
dans le complexe dans le contradictoire
et que si vous voulez si on emploie le
langage marxiste hégélien de la thèse
antithèse synthèse en ce moment dès
qu'on arrive à la synthèse il faut
retourner très vite à la contradiction à
la thèse et l'antithèse c'est vrai que
j'ai ce tendance en ce moment et comme
peut-être toujours à chérir davantage
des questions de des réponses et enfin
et enfin peut-être cela vient que je
m'occupe des fonctions d'éditorialistes
et l'un des plus grands éditorialistes
qui ait jamais existé en américain
walter lippmann disait que notre métier
consistait à faire peut sérieusement des
choses qui vous inviter à vous prendre
au sérieux
et dieu sait pourtant si votre
alignement était un homme savant dans
les sciences politiques
mais il disait que devant devant sa
table au moment d'écrire un éditorial
sur le ton sentencieux donneurs de
leçons magistère enfin une fonction même
un petit peu magistral eh bien il se dit
il faisait la somme de ces ignorances la
somme de ses lacunes et il pensait à
tous les livres qu'il aurait voulu lire
et comme c'est mon cas
alors dans ces moments là on n'a pas du
tout envie d'être
militant c'est à dire des cartes et du
réel de le mutiler tout ce qui ne sert
pas votre cause on a envie au contraire
de regarder de s'inviter soi même à une
certaine modestie et plus aux
éditorialistes et plus on a envie si
vous voulez de ceux de s'ouvrir le reste
au moment où on quitte cette page ont
manqué de cette fonction et pour ma part
enfin si vous voulez et je crois que ce
sera peut-être subjectivement plus
important je me suis sentie toujours un
peu atteint de claustrophobie dont
j'étais enfermé à l'intérieur d'un corps
futile le camp le plus juste celui que
je crois être celui du socialisme c'est
le parti le camp des opprimés le camp
des victimes j'ai toujours envie de
regarder au delà par dessus la barrière
pour voir si un bras ne se tend pas
qu'on n'a pas saisi un visage ne nous
regarde pas qui qu'il ya une lumière une
idée n'est pas là de ce côté au delà de
nous que nous avons refusé et qui
pourtant nous enrichir et si vous voulez
avant je vivais dans les cars tellement
parce que c'était au fond la traduction
intellectuelle de la contradiction et
puis dès que j'ai découvert que la
vérité était cette contradiction
je vis dans une sorte non pas d'harmonie
mais de quasi sérénité car je crois j'ai
la quasi certitude que c'est au travers
de cette contradiction que je m'approche
ray le plus dur elle
[Musique]